the great Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger
look at him look at this marble engine
look at you gorgeous god bless you look
at you governor how are you please
Jimmy's here Robin's here governor has
anyone officially welcomed over Los
Angeles oh that's your I'm gonna do that
do I officially welcome you to Los
Angeles that the paradise of the world
you love you love Ellen because Jimmy
you didn't welcome him you're gonna do
it you're gonna do it a new show I will
welcome I'm on the show meanwhile so
silly I mean welcome II tell everyone
you think about it I mean Tom wise not
silly because I could do the same show
in New York you know what I'm saying it
doesn't matter but it's great to have
you here and I'm ecstatic when I heard
that you're coming to LA I said it
myself I want to be on this show when
you come still they they're so fantastic
you want the greatest guy to do this for
me
seriously I'm being serious Jimmy - I
mean the fact that you guys would even
care to get up this early and come over
here are you kidding me I mean I mean we
love you Howard you did are you kidding
me now every single time I've done an
interview with you vo at the great time
and the reaction of the people after
which was always fantastic why because
you are great [ __ ] interviewer thank
you mean you're just a natural you don't
you know write down the questions and
you kind of come up like a program tell
me now when did you start working out
okay what was it like when you grew up
with your father I heard he was very
disciplinary yeah is this a poor [ __ ]
but so you you can have developed like
this these last hours I've been driving
in here from Santa Monica and I've been
listening to you guys today it is such a
pleasure to listen to you guys talk
because it's a natural talk that guys do
when they hang out in the gym or at home
when you smoke a stogie or something
like that right play chess that's how
you talk you playing chess these days
yeah I want to play with you I mean
you'll kick my ass but I want a hug I'm
not that good I'm just I just love play
I said about you in the book and I
really do believe this about your
governor that the the fact is the way I
relate to you is we both had this in
same drive to be known to the world I
really do feel that I was on a mission
to somehow stand out to be seen and I
feel both of us really had that need
inside of us to be seen am i accurate
about that you're absolutely correct I
think that we both have I think the old
three can say that that we have the same
drive you know do not not like the two
of you but yeah you know oh come on no
are we I'm driven you're absolutely
right I mean we know it's just you and I
know what are we we just like to shoot
for the top did we mean I mean one of my
rules to success when I give seminars
and lectures about the inner
motivational speeches and stuff like
that is shoot for the top don't go and
shoot for something little and this is
where I always said when I was getting
into acting I did not want to be an
actor I wanted to be a leading man I
wanted to be the highest paid
entertainer I wanted to be above the
title that's what I was shooting for
why should for something little right
when in bodybuilding I didn't want to be
mr. universe and want to be the greatest
bodybuilder of all time